Canada's official motto translates as
from sea to sea but for many years now
there's been an unofficial version from
sea to sea to sea because Karen doesn't
just have west and east coasts it has a
North one as well just over that hill is
Inuvik a small town about 3,000 people
in the Northwest Territories about 200
kilometers north of the Arctic Circle
but it's not on the Arctic Ocean until
recently this was the end of the
Dempster highway that was far north as
you could get by Canada's road system
there wasn't a continuous link from C to
C to C except in winter when the ice was
frozen enough to support vehicles but in
2017 after years of difficult
construction over the permafrost and
hundreds of millions of dollars in costs
an all-weather highway finally opened
from here to Tuktoyaktuk on the Arctic
Ocean so for the first time we can drive
there all we could take it like it turns
out the building all-weather highway
across permafrost is an incredibly
difficult logistical challenge it's now
spring time the thaw is beginning and
large section of the highway particular
in the south have pretty much turned to
murder there isn't quite enough ground
isn't compact enough it isn't cold
enough if your vehicle gets caught there
you are hours from help and you have no
cell phone service so for safety
the government has closed the road at
least for now but sooner or later the
road will be fixed and the highway will
reopen and touch the actor will be
connected together and that's gonna
change things here I was born and raised
here 21 years ago but anyways I love it
here all my life never gonna move enjoy
my life here there is just under a
thousand people that Divya Vee around we
do a lot of fishing not a hunting Harry
pickin what not do the seasonal thing
when they got to go ahead to finally
start building the road took about five
years and they would only work in a
winter time because the Tundra's frozen
and they want to damage the tundra
because once a poor enforce a surface
the Swiss are mouthing they would make
ice bridges even to where they would
haul the gravel source just so they
don't do damage doctor your talk is not
isolated anymore
mostly year round so Fiona goes travel
down south you just hop on your vehicle
if you own a vehicle just head down for
a summer months would be isolated would
wait for the scheduled flight to come in
or it go by boat with your own a boat
most people were four they were hoping
the prices would go down four goes to
his gas what not and the gas price did
go down a bit because we had a second
gas in open up so there's that it's one
of the good things all it just gives
more opportunity for everybody now want
to be clear this is not some abandoned
Arctic outpost this cell phone service
here there's a lot of people this fast
internet Eileen who I interviewed she
runs the local taxi service this is a
proper town it's just very far north the
future of the Canadian Arctic is unknown
right now climate change means that the
permafrost is melting sea level rise is
already threatening this town this
highway is just gonna be one more change
in a century of them we never did film
actually because hill from here
yeah we're just used to use it the way
we were living on a thing
you